this is one of our best-selling bags at
the moon designer retailer brand owner
and founder Graham Ellison is nothing if
not hands-on his company Osprey makes
luxurious leather goods like this bag
the Avery which sells for five hundred
and forty seven dollars it's been
labeled affordable luxury it's all about
the quality of the Italian hide it's
about how well it's been stitched how
well it's supported here it all began in
1980 when a young Graham and his friend
decided they wanted to set out on their
own we had five hundred pounds and we
borrowed five hundred pounds from the
bank and we had a pocket full of dreams
and that was a start point
Osprey now counts both rock and real
royalty amongst its clients it's just
opened a flagship store in London's
luxury shopping mecca Regent Street
you'll find in the store we've got
butterflies beetles bugs taxidermy
skulls bones bits and bobs like that
these are the things which I really
enjoy I'm a frustrated naturalist Osprey
banks on its British roots but the
company's success lies in its ability to
think globally I think it's been the
story of our times fact in many respects
we were an artisan manufacturer we
designed and made the product with our
own hands in England in Hertfordshire in
fact and right the way through now to
2014 where actually we make very little
in the UK ourselves and we manufacture a
whole array of products globally source
Graham knows he can no longer do it all
himself Osprey is growing up and for
that he needs help
this is something that we do the family
are all involved and now we have a
hundred and thirty people that work for
us who are also part of the same
collaborative team so we're a big family
working
honest